[Musik]
der 15 jährige kilian macht das was er
am liebsten tut
modellfliegen seit er denken kann will
er pilot werden
seit seiner geburt jedoch kämpfte junge
mit einem starken adhs er ist ein
schlechter schüler und ein klassischer
zappelphilipp darum bekommt er seit neun
jahren ein medikament dagegen
[Musik]
vor sechs jahren haben wir kilian zum
ersten mal gefilmt er war neun jahre alt
und mit dem schulstoff heillos
überfordert schon damals war klar dass
er es in der normalen schule nicht
schaffen würde
auch der zwölfjährige dominik hatte
damals probleme in der schule
zudem war er ein träumer und hatte außer
mit seinem bruder kaum soziale kontakte
nun sechs jahre später steht dominique
ganz woanders im leben
er hat eben eine lehre in einer
landschaftsgärtnerei begonnen die dritte
die wir damals begleitet haben war die
14-jährige silly
sie war mit allem schnell überfordert
und reagierte zu hause mit heftigen
wutausbrüchen und verzweiflung
heute lernt sie polymechaniker wie geht
es den drei jugendlichen und wie kommen
sie klar mit ihrer veranlagung nicht nur
etwa fünf prozent der kinder und
jugendlichen haben ein adhs ebenso viele
erwachsene sind davon betroffen
denn mittlerweile ist klar adhs wächst
sich nicht aus der musiker miguel calero
weiß was das heißt
er kämpft auch heute noch damit es ist
ja bekannt dass ich gerade so wie alice
burnout-symptome also mit allem
überfordert zieht sarah heißt stärkt
grad alles ich merk notbremse ziehen
zwar knapp wird in positive menschen die
ich sehe da komm ich wieder raus aber
ich nun mit 16 und lernen ein segen
kilian übt mit seinem therapeuten beim
modellfliegen wie er besser mit der
dauernden überforderung umgehen kann
er muss lernen sich besser zu
konzentrieren und zu kontrollieren schon
vor sechs jahren war mangelnde
selbstkontrolle sein größtes problem
er verlor schnell die nerven und war auf
dem pausenplatz dauernd in irgendwelche
schlägereien verwickelt
kilian hat mittlerweile drei
schulwechsel hinter sich vor kurzem hat
er an einer neuen privaten schule mit
der oberstufe begonnen noch knapp drei
jahre bleiben ihm bis er ins berufsleben
einsteigen muss seine mutter daniela
findet er habe es im moment gut im griff
[Musik]
als kühler wird immer selbstständiger
als ich danke der schulberg meister der
altstadt neu aufnimmt cm sehr früh steht
ja gott pünktlich aus dem haus er
strukturiert sich es nicht läuft
komplett zahlbar machte wagen therapien
sagt ständig und ich würde sagen
jugendpsychologe roland abwickeln
begleitet kilian seit vier jahren
er findet sein schützling könne sich
auch besser kontrollieren eingriff
frustrationstoleranz sich besser über
kohl blieb pilot muss auch cool blieb
aber dass jetzt noch in tucson mal
probieren ob das irgendwie noch mehr
anstellen ja
das mit der frustrationstoleranz ist sie
doch immer noch eine fragile sache
wie möglich zurückzahlen
alles rund um die schule ist schwierig
für kinder mit adhs
[Musik]
miguel calero ging es ähnlich auch seine
probleme begannen schon ganz früh mini
suizid gar nicht als sehr schweren
punkte
ich bin sehr auffällig sei der schule
sehr mühe keine schuhe ich bin ein
extremer treue ob sie erhebliche zum
hörtest schickt weil ich der lehrkörper
der lehre beim match schweiz nicht
angehört
ich bin kein guter schüler sich bisher
sehr schlechtes verhalten ionix
klassisch klasse klang sie ja und lehrer
nicht zufrieden mit mir
trotzdem hat er versucht seinen weg zu
gehen da immer wüsste dass ich bisher
sicher bin das habe ich sie immer da und
ich an ihm habe ich glaube das ist
wahnsinnig gestärkt wie froh ich das
immer und ich war die lügen glaubt wo
mir gesagt hat man immer gesagt du bist
du nicht fähig und durchaus nicht immer
gesagt warten bis ich groß bin ich wird
überwiesen und dort zeigen was ich bin
und dass ich ok kamera hat der
ursprünglich briefträger gelernt heute
gibt er beatbox unterricht an der
schaffhauser musikschule und das obwohl
er nie ein lehrer oder musik patent
gemacht hat sein feuer für die musik hat
gereicht um die musikschulleiterin zu
überzeugen
workshops käsbauer jahr lang immer
wieder und kekse und die stadt ahlen
sprach sie und das kultur- und 500 wenig
das macht mit den kids und wie reagiert
und unterricht
[Musik]
caro hat es geschafft seinen traum zu
leben doch er kämpft immer noch mit
seinem adressen
deshalb versucht er als botschafter
verständnis dafür zu schaffen
in schaffhausen findet eine tagung für
lehrer und lehrmeister zum thema statt
[Musik]
das ist mit mir nicht stimmt sein ist
für mich und ich habe nie bewusst war
was das ist und ich habe einen
sperrbezirk in als buch anfangen also
adhs in der beziehung und wäre dem ich
das buch liest
ich musste sind alter ständig probleme
also der das licht die aufgang und
schließlich trikot 6
es gibt inzwischen kennt er sich gut und
weiß wie er auf sich achten kann
medikamente nimmt er nicht so extrem
wird die innere uhr ist sobald ich mich
länger über längere zeit muss
grundzentren für bis formats büroarbeit
und zu e mails denn dann geht es über
florida unterlag schüttler durch
einatmen damit mich wieder konzentrieren
und hat mehr kraft mit körper verteilt
das nicht so dazu die wichtigsten davon
ja unter blauen extrem laut und mal
organisierten einmal total unorganisiert
und lasse sich nicht einfach aber es ist
ja das schlimme kämpfe wie andré oder
schlimme ist immer anstrengend
prominenter redner an der tagung ist der
psychiater und adhs spezialist heiner
lachenmeier
er gilt als koryphäe auf dem gebiet und
kämpft dafür dass adhs nicht einfach als
marke wahrgenommen wird
zuerst muss man sagen die konditionen
dass ich heute haben wir das als sichere
sich als österreicher durch genetisch
vererbt
ein chemischer prozess im gehirn macht
den unterschied und führt dazu dass
alles was von außen kommt weniger gut
gefiltert wird
das schematisch so darstelle drinkuth so
alles was ihn nach unten der hund eine
automatische filter und logische
riesiges den relativ einfach schnellen
überblick zu bekommen
über den ads und war sich alle infos
ihnen
es bliebe unglaublich viel variante und
es sich logisch wenn wir das wenn man es
so funktioniert denn kurz landesmutter
überblick hat und möglicherweise gibt
dass eine überlastung also nicht nur
vorträge sie moderieren in die frei
wachsen danke sondern sich ein mangel
massive überlastung im herbst treffen
wir kilian wieder seine welt ist gerade
total aus den fugen geraten nach nur
zwei monaten ist er aus der neuen schule
geflogen
er ist wieder über sein altes problem
gestolpert hat sich mit einem
schulkollegen geprügelt
und dann muss ich das hier habe der
schulleiter
[Musik]
seit zwei wochen ist kilian zu hause
niemand weiß wie es weitergeht
seine mutter ist auf dem weg zur
anwältin und suchtrat daniela ist aus
allen wolken gefallen muss sich um eine
neue lösung kümmern und macht sich
natürlich große sorgen um ihren sohn
natürlich oder sozialen umfeld des
escort im sicher manchmal vermittelt das
gefühl nichts mit ihm
das macht es nicht einfacher aber er
halte sich an die region an die
strukturen die ich daheim katar wo ich
aufgebe
das macht der arbeit ich danke auch
wieder froh wenn aber deine schulsystem
in der untersten show langweilig kilian
macht zwar seine aufgaben hängt aber
tatsächlich im luftleeren raum
seine tage sind lang
[Musik]
einfach muss man leider dass er so
schnell explodiert ist seit er denken
kann sein problem
psychiater einer lachenmaier weiß warum
menschen mit adhs so schnell die fassung
verlieren das wäre mit dem sind die wohl
negativ sind wie eine kritik oder so
hier stoße den dollar bis nach führen
und denn dort sich wieder blicken
das gibt den hypo fokus und negative
hypo focus in euren blick und denn ich
das um was es geht plötzlich riesig und
der ist reaktionen der ja viel größer
und wir auch sehr viel schneller extrem
wichtig es gibt missverständnis und
ruckzuck ist natürlich eine eskalation
denn vorhanden weil daniela weiß dass
kilian so funktioniert ist das ihr
besonders wichtig dass sie auf die
schulwahl einfluss nehmen kann
sie leistet sich einen termin bei einer
anwältin weil sie verhindern will dass
kilian in die öffentliche sonderschule
um geteilt wird
da daniela keine finanziellen mittel hat
hängt alles davon ab was der kanton
luzern entscheidet wichtig ist dass das
auge berufs konkret sind und das
bedürfnis von hin und unter schule so
breit ich mir jetzt dieser
untersuchungen im kanton luzern sind da
natürlich denn eigentlich für
kriegshelden heimat denn die
schwierigkeit die richtige schule für
kilian zu finden
das ist die große herausforderung
als wir dominiert vor sechs jahren das
erste mal begleitet haben bei 12 und
hatte ebenfalls große schulische
probleme
zudem war er sehr introvertiert und
hatte keine freunde medikamente hatte er
aber nur ganz kurz genommen
[Musik]
nun ist dominik 17 jahre alt und hat vor
ein paar monaten eine lehre als
landschaftsgärtner begonnen
schon immer hat sich dominik in der
natur wohl gefühlt dass er nun draußen
arbeiten kann gefällt ihm viel besser
als die schulbank zu drücken
auch wenn der wechsel nicht ganz einfach
war die schwierigste die arbeitszeit ist
aber zu viel längeren rückstau und es
ist ja auch nicht doch quant schafft das
schon zu seinem leidwesen ist die schule
noch nicht ganz um in der berufsschule
sind seine leistungen bisher ungenügend
wenn er so weitermacht muss er die lehre
in vier statt drei jahren machen
glücklicherweise kann er aber auf die
unterstützung seines lehrmeisters zählen
es ist nicht ganz auf den baustellen
oder mehr geduld aufbringen
er beruft sich länger bis er bis kapiert
was das meer immer als mache ja aber im
großen und ganzen aber das macht ihn
traurig und schaufelt er mit und dass
das funktioniert so wie das bei dominik
zu hause ist man alarmiert wegen der
schlechten schulnoten
dabei hat alles recht gut begonnen aber
er muss jetzt aktiv ihre knochen mit dem
chef der nord liegt und sie gab es dann
jetzt die chance dass er wirklich das in
new york machen und die zahlen nach
liege kozmus mit mir einfach die pflanze
zweimal in der woche freundlich 1 ab und
muss ja was mit der note nach oben wäre
ja auch wenn es mit dem lernen noch arzt
sozial ist dominique heute kein
außenseiter mehr
seit bald einem jahr hatte eine freundin
das hat sein leben grundlegend verändert
kennengelernt hat er sarah bei seinem
alten hobby dem hapkido mittlerweile
gehört dominik zu den erfahrensten hier
das eher introvertiert ist damit hat
sarah überhaupt kein problem mit dem
gestritten
wenn also respekt von den ort und das
ist einfach schöner unsere beziehung bin
ich also ich finde damit passe zusammen
denn ich bin früh erschöpft sie und wenn
es jetzt noch so bitz und darum was wir
zusammen
sie finden die gleichen games und filme
gut und verbringen jede freie minute
zusammen mit sarah ist viel sonne in
dominiks leben getreten
sie geht für rolf da weil ich in der
mannschaft nicht ich mag die stärke und
hoffnung
heiner lachenmaier plädiert generell
dafür dass man bei menschen mit adhs
weniger auf die negativen auswirkungen
schaut es geht
negative sache wieder vergessen und
sport und so wie du und das nervt
natürlich und da wo aber die andere
sieht den ich gerade erst sind häufig
sehr hilfsbereit und findet neue lösung
sagt das ist für gesellschaft sehr
positiv mittlerweile kennt man viele war
sehr innovativ krisen 6 in der
wissenschaft und technik und kunst sport
oder war immer was los in das theater
rigiblick in zürich erlebt einen großen
aufschwung 22 jahre danach sagt
margarete du erhalte wieder nach unten
grund dafür ist auch ein umtriebiger
theaterdirektor der schauspieler daniel
rohr rohr hat auch ein adhs
aber er hat es geschafft seine
veranlagung positiv umzusetzen
er ist ein chaot und hans dampf in allen
gassen und reist pausenlos neue projekte
an
[Gelächter]
so scheint es brauche zeit
ich bin entweder im opera oder im büro
das er zappelig ist sieht man sofort
er führt das theater spielt selbst und
hat 1000 neue ideen pro tag
seine rechte hand brigitta star hell
schätzt die kreative zusammenarbeit mit
ihm sehr immer schoss nach dem kopf so
lang zu hause schnell abgeschlossen
begriff schnell und nachher show thema
vor dem er ist effizient ein
riesenschwein mitarbeitende also dass
man sagt ja fließend vieles auch das
spiel für mich bestimmt 200 prozent oder
und blüht wo gott sei dank des
verstehens interesse verliert beharrlich
dran der bibel
diese ad-hoc gestärkt das ist ganz
wichtig was gab es um wahrlich sehr
wichtig
[Musik]
du hast auf außenstehende wirkt alles
ein bisschen chaotisch hier also ich
fühle mich im haus wohl
wir machen das nicht aus es gibt
situationen wo ich jetzt mache das
gewicht oder wo ich im verkehr sagt aber
wir sind natürlich auch es unglaublich
effektiv steam dafür nicht der fsb zu
die hsg und damit praktisch und da
finden sagte zettel der hamam ist klar
dass man das vorher besprochen
ich weiß es nicht gesehen die
serverkosten schöne zuvor berichtet 17
da haben wir noch die 100 stieg um noch
nicht abgeschrieben
das gibt dann kann ich die neue gruppe
vormachen wie viele erwachsene hat rohr
erst durch seine kinder erkannt dass er
ein adhs hat
ich möchte meine tochter wenn meine
tochter hat abklärung und und meine
tochter schwierig ist spieler kubik sie
also sicherlich sehr fehlen es auch die
jahrhundert so dass sie ganz starke
legasthenie hat war nicht mehr haben und
mir die show klar sie mir hat mir immer
gesagt die mission zu philipp man hat
mir immer in der schule im kongo und die
wasser überall jetzt auch mal jetzt hebt
doch mal was muss ich bin als schüler
sehr sehr viel vor der tür gestanden
weil ich einfach schwarz schwarz gespart
ich am start und ich aber sehr darunter
gelitten dass ich immer mehr führe das
hat mich getroffen
das weiß natürlich dass pubertierende
gibt mir das nicht so und wie tesco
aber es hat mich kann ich bin hetero wo
das buch das erklärt wird dass heime für
der lehrer braucht hat die anne könig
und die lehrerschaft halt mit sport
nicht verdient dass ich sehr viel dampf
auch eine notlage schulisch hat rohr
eine typische schlangen karriere hinter
sich
zuerst banklehre dann gymnasium lehrer
ausbildung und dann erst schauspieler
heute kommt ihnen das alles irgendwie zu
gute kommen spiele noch mit behinderung
haben 23 russ druckt und natürlich
versichert zu schritt instrumentalspiel
nachträglich versteht er gut dass er für
sein umfeld eine große herausforderung
war
ich glaube man muss bei zieht er
verstehe aber dass vor der lehrer her
ganz schwierig sich für mich dass das
ein schüler durften sich die ganzen
lieben tag nach der großen erfolgreichen
herrscht sicher so dass ich
wahrscheinlich sehr sehr anstrengend für
die lehrerin oder für den lehrer kilian
darf nach drei monaten zu hause endlich
zweimal wöchentlich in die
nachhilfestunde seine alte schule
übernimmt nach langem hin und her die
kosten
die pensionierte schulleiterin ursula
scherer hat kilian schon früher in
krisenzeiten unterrichtet
bei ihr fühlt er sich gut aufgehoben es
ist so und noch schwierige situation für
ältere und die mutter wenn der kanton so
lange bis man an flüssigkeit weil der
kanton ische brandorte kreieren sie für
schuldig und hätte ja zu dem projekt
classics und das mache da drüben quasi
im detail auf das sich für mich
unverständlich
kilians größtes schulisches problem ist
mathe als oberstufenschüler hat er
selbst die einfachsten operationen noch
nicht kapiert
ja aber wäre ein geschätzter ihm allein
feiern mit dem gericht mit man spürt was
jetzt dass wir bis jetzt an den basics
600 rumäne blues - und über den rhein
lässt dass ich mir selbst gemacht
ich habe nur verliert
[Musik]
oft traut sich kilian auch zu wenig zu
weil er davon ausgeht sowieso nichts zu
verstehen
das hat damit zu tun dass die lernkurve
bei menschen mit adhs langer flacher
verläuft als bei den anderen sagt heiner
lachenmeier
wenn alle informationen kritik die könne
den besucher der automatisch alles small
office und das kk mensch der verliert
mit der überblick und er hätten das
gefühl gehabt nicht gelernt ton gott
lernkurve floss und wenn sich deine
posts ersetzten jugendlager behaupte den
kann man praktisch blind auf das andere
hab mir sehr guten überblick häufig
besser wie andere daheim versucht kilian
seine hausaufgaben zu lösen
aber sein gehirn spielt ihm regelmäßig
einen streich
um dort durch ein automatischer vorbild
soll wohl heißen phase die größere zahl
zudem spürt er natürlich den druck und
macht sich auch sorgen um seine zukunft
nach langen vier monaten zeichnet sich
aber nun doch endlich eine schulische
lösung ab
daniela hat bescheid vom kanton bekommen
weil die beiden sonderschulen in luzern
voll sind soll kilian nach den
sportferien in eine sonderschule im
kanton zürich eingeschult werden
daniela hat gemischte gefühle
die alleinerziehende arbeitet teilzeit
und muss sich fügen eine privatschule
kann sie sich nicht leisten
einerseits bin ich sehr happy dass er
wieder eine schulhof eine strukturierte
sach und anthrazit ist es schwierig will
sich halten sonderschule ich bin immer
noch der meinung nur unter verhalten
zufällig i can t schnitte geeignete ort
schlussendlich muss jetzt auch auf cd
lernstand muss aufholen
also eine öffentliche schule das nicht
funktionieren werden überfordert ist vom
lernstoff
ich hoffe dass er vor allem dann halt
wirklich eine dreijährige lehre könnte
ich das gefühl das wird ja schon
schaffen
vor allem aber muss der lernstand hat es
ist einfach jetzt wichtig bevor es aber
um die berufswahl geht muss kilian
erstmal den einstieg in die neue schule
meistern
er hat sich viel vorgenommen viele
vorsätze aber es kommt nicht nur auf
kilians verhalten an sagt psychiater
heiner lachenmaier also ganz wichtig ist
dass man eine gute beziehung zu der
personengruppe lehrmeister das geht eine
möglichkeit besser sich im stoff zu
orientieren und überhaupt was muss ich
machen und da die motivation finden sie
riet setzte auf der basis von der
beziehung dass ich hinterher wie kleine
kinder war das anfangs schuhe sind alle
buche bucht man das auge isst ja und
wenn man erzählt risch bei der
19-jährigen zellen funktioniert das seit
sie in der lehre ist gut jetzt als
polymechaniker in kann sie endlich mit
den händen arbeiten
sie ist gerade mitten in der
lehrabschlussprüfung dass sie ein adhs
hat hat sie im lehrbetrieb von anfang an
gesagt ich will nicht im nachhinein
eines autos und du musst berücksichtigt
kann vor was sache ist dass ich heute
dass ritalin horn und das war ein
interesse haben das ist ein prinzip das
man zum beispiel vieles schief läuft und
das ist auch mal einfach so akzeptiert
worden hat man so einem 77 stellt und
hat dann mit einem sind kann erklärt und
gehör verschaffen
ritalin im ziel in seit langem
es hilft ihr sich zu konzentrieren bis
sie mit der ausbildung fertig ist will
sie das medikament sicher nicht absetzen
ich denke man sich jetzt komplett ohne
italiener geschossen
jetzt da wo man kann unterschieden es
gibt da funktioniert vor schluss nicht
geleistet
dieses gefühl hat zählen in der
schulzeit oft erlebt auch noch als wir
sie vor sechs jahren das erste mal
begleitet haben ging oft gar nichts mehr
[Musik]
celine war ehrgeizig aber der alltag
kostete sie so viel kraft dass sie schon
mittags ausgelaugt war wut und frust
bestimmten ihr leben bis sich die mutter
entschied das arbeitspensum zu
reduzieren um celine zu hause optimal
begleiten zu können
schweren herzens versuchte sie es auch
mit dem umstrittenen ritalin und deshalb
psychiater lachenmaier präzisiert wann
medikamente sinnvoll sind
diagnose ads gestellt worden ist er
immer belege dafür und am besten ist es
dort aber auch wenn es um die animago
passieren als dass neurobiologische der
projekts ritalin am besten wörter muss
ihnen direkt ist also wenn du so sein
dass man die schwierigkeit entstanden
sind
das muss man vor allem augen sprache das
bespreche extrem wichtig auch wenn
allenfalls trotzdem ritalin bucht celine
hatte viel unterstützung
mittlerweile hat sie ihren platz im
leben gefunden
ihr freund und zwei kollegen holen sie
von der arbeit ab
ihre freunde wissen von ihrem adhs
tochter celine gelernt hat mit ihrer
inneren unruhe besser umzugehen fällt
sie heute nicht mehr speziell auf und
sie hat auch gemerkt dass es noch andere
gibt die mit ähnlichen problemen kämpfen
eine andere kollegin salma es hat zwar
erklärt sich dann den wohnt bei ihren
eltern in der nähe von winterthur auch
heute noch braucht sie ganz klare
rituale und strukturen
seit jahren gibt es immer punkt 6 uhr
abendessen
sonst verliert sie sofort die nerven
früher gab es deswegen oft krach mit
ihrem vater und ihrer mutter meine dinge
die man nur lustig ab und zu mal wenn
sie kocht duldet sie jedoch nach wie vor
niemanden sonst in der küche dass es
anstrengend ist mit einem kind mit adhs
das wusste salans mutter schon aus ihrer
eigenen kindheit als von minister der
zauberer ist und die frage ist was das
bedeutet was uns für den user fordern
für alle beteiligten für die person nur
sauber hat und dafür die anderen
familienmitglieder kann ich weiß dass
das ein langer schlaf braucht
dass das viel kraft und zeit braucht und
ich habe einfach ganzen hof und das hat
natürlich wo man dann diagnose kann
peter seel in mir schlafen muss mal was
das bedeutet aber ich denke mir an
wir haben die voraussetzungen zum tragen
reagieren ruf und wissen natürlich hotel
in sciacca hat und auch eine andere
stufe reagiere und unter c liga
dass das nach vorne trägt sie ist für
die ganze familie haben und riet oder
weiß filme brothers oder hotels und
mache sich auch die entsprechende
unterstützung holen also ich bin zum
beispiel das hat mir wirklich sehr gut
von einfach als merkel
da gibt es andere leute genau die
griffigen unser vorträge zu bewältigen
und das kommt gar nicht erfreut ist die
älter sind oder die jünger aus mir wird
es dir jetzt ihr alleinerziehend sind
wird die ewige und geschäftsführer sport
oscar rolle des kindes mit lässig oder
hamburg y familie sein einzel handys
oder psychische probleme sind einfach
alle griff hellen jeans tochter celine
neigt eher zu perfektionismus für
psychiater heiner lachenmaier ist dass
einer von zwei extreme formen wie sich
adhs äußern kann
und da sind ja ein die sitte nicht dass
man einfach den kontakt und den
entscheidet menu und der ladung im chaos
und die andere ist dass man einfach
versucht alles zu machen
dann entscheidet man eigentlich alle zum
perfektionist und da kann man sehr
erfolgreich sie der preis dafür ist dass
man relativ schnell erschöpft sie und
ich sehe in der box ist immer wieder um
die 40 umeinander sich man halt mit
schöpf zuerst ein burnout etc und den
findet man denn dass die eigentliche
jetzt sind wo überkompensieren dann
unter den perfektionismus ihn ergangen
sind
theaterdirektor daniel rohr ist
definitiv der chaotische typ er ist
immer noch hyperaktiv macht alles
gleichzeitig und nimmt auch dauernd
alles war aber je älter er wurde desto
besser konnte er seine ganz persönlichen
strategien entwickeln medikamente hat er
nie genommen
aber er bewegt sich täglich in der natur
und ich glaube das war ganz wichtig ist
dass ich wirklich analyse gemacht haben
dass ich sehr viel von mir weiß dass ich
natürlich haben bruder von als
schauspieler sehr viel über sich selber
wisse zu flüssig für eine derart stelle
ich glaube es ist sehr wichtig dass man
weiß wer ich das wirklich froh danke
linda ronstadt erkennen die ich selbst
das ist einfach sei es wichtig wenn man
dann vielleicht andere sachen
relativieren gewisses leiter vor allem
wieder die tv ton relativiere nicht
unbedingt entschuldige aber auch
relativieren so viel selbstreflexion ist
erst in einem gewissen alter möglich
darum findet dass daniel rohr wichtig
dass man offen über adhs spricht ich
glaube dass sich befreien wenn man weiß
was er sich etwas besser stufen sich
anstelle der klassischen teil von mir
aber sicher ist wo mit mir ob ich es
machen
das ist und mich drüber bis 21
[Musik]
er hat auf seiner veranlagung das
bestmögliche gemacht seine überschüssige
energie keiner heute gut kanalisieren
und auf der bühne ausleben
jetzt bei uns zum beispiel lampen über
land auf jegliche form wo energie für
ganz so starke energie wenn ich es
schaffe die energie zu richten
da kann das sehr gut sie für den
theaterring oder und soll so vor energie
dieser ford den floh aus dem haus und
der untergehenden blutroten mond schien
jetzt hell durch den einst kaum
wahrnehmbaren riss von dem ich bereits
sagte dass er vom dach des hauses im
zickzack zum erdboden lied das von rund
des mondes wurde eine breit
aufgerissenen spalt sich da mein geist
st als ich die gewaltigen mauern
auseinander bersten und der schwarzen
und die verteilt zu meinen füßen
schlosses finster und schweigend über
den hausarzt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wenn nur kilian seiner energien auch so
gut kanalisieren könnte er ist bei
seinem psychologen seit drei wochen ist
er an der neuen schule aber der lang
ersehnte schulstart ist alles andere als
glücklich verlaufen
das ist stress vor hexen ja da ist
wirklich sehr schwierig sie erstens
aufgrund vor der vorfahre der schlächter
vorerfahrungen angst was passiert an der
neuen schule hat das wieder passieren
jetzt auch fehler passieren ich sehr
unter druck sie einerseits und
andererseits alles ist neu sie also ein
mythos alles ist neu es ist ungewohnt
das ist einfach eine neue jahr fragen
über gagen
das ist verfällt mit adhs immer
schwierig und prompt hat in sein altes
problem wieder eingeholt
am ersten tag schon kam es zu einem
konflikt mit einem mitschüler
[Musik]
das alles zusammen hat kilian in eine
große krise gestürzt er hatte schwere
angstzustände panikattacken und konnte
nicht mehr schlafen
[Musik]
zum glück hat sich die situation wieder
etwas beruhigt in der gruppen schule
thalwil hat man viel erfahrung mit adhs
kindern dass es am anfang
schwierigkeiten gibt kommt vor
die schule hat sofort reagiert und den
konflikt zwischen den beiden
streithähnen entspannt kilian zudem sehr
eng geführt und hat praktisch eine
eins-zu-eins-betreuung auch wenn es
nicht einfach ist in mathe versucht die
lehrerin geduldig die vielen löcher zu
stopfen
[Musik]
kilian gefällt's die enge führung tut
ihm gut
[Musik]
erstmal muss kilian nun seine
medikamente um ein viertel reduzieren
die sonderschule verwendet zudem viel
energie darauf für die kinder hier nach
der schulzeit eine passende berufs
lösung zu finden
stiftungsrat gianni motti ist überzeugt
dass kilian sofern er mitmacht auch mit
seinem handicap eine berufliche
perspektive hat ich denke halt wenn man
das doch konsequent die uhrzeit und
weimar industrie bringt team hat durch
die bessere chance als 17 oder den
landwirten richtige streaming will
ganz intensiv politik gemacht wird dann
schnuppere noch eine zum teil
wöchentlich schnupper überein
und wo man ganz genau erklärt sich an
einige fähigkeiten und zurück und busy
die richtig erstellt
langsam fast kilian vertrauen
also wenn ich gut mit machten sich aus
der schule fliegen und ich warte jetzt
einfach dass die schulregeln dass die
perfekte schule ist geblieben und hat
auch einen gäbe bissig fußball der hand
zwei jahre hat kilian noch zeit den
schulstoff aufzuholen
alle wissen es und er auch der ball
liegt nun bei ihm mit der unterstützung
die er hat etwas aus der neuen situation
zu machen
[Musik]